et nous demander si l'on voulait du vin.
J'ai dit : « D'accord, je vais prendre du vin blanc. »
Et elle a immédiatement répondu :
« Voulez-vous du sauvignon blanc ou du chardonnay ? »
Et je me souviens avoir pensé :
« Allons, Madame, arrêtez un peu avec le français
et servez-moi un peu de vin blanc. »
En utilisant mes facultés de déduction,
j'ai compris que chardonnay et sauvignon blanc
était deux types de vin bien distincts,
et je lui ai donc dit que je prendrais du chardonnay,
car honnêtement, c'était le plus facile à prononcer.
J'ai eu de nombreuses expériences similaires
pendant mes deux premières années de droit à Yale,
car en dépit des apparences, je viens d'un autre milieu.
Je ne viens pas des élites.
Je ne viens pas du Nord-Est ou de San Francisco.
Je viens d'une ville sidérurgique du sud de l'Ohio,
c'est une ville qui lutte de nombreuses manières,
révélatrices des luttes plus larges
de la classe ouvrière américaine.
L'héroïne s'est installée,
tuant beaucoup de monde, des gens que je connaissais.
La violence domestique et le divorce ont déchiré bien des familles.
Et un certain pessimisme s'est installé.
Prenez la hausse du taux de mortalité dans ces communautés,
pour beaucoup de ces gens,
les problèmes qu'ils voient
sont vraiment la cause de la hausse du taux de mortalité dans leur communauté,
il y a un vrai sentiment de lutte.
J'ai été au premier rang de cette lutte.
Ma famille a fait partie de cette lutte pendant très longtemps.
Je viens d'une famille qui n'avait pas beaucoup d'argent.
L'addiction qui a touché ma communauté
a aussi touché ma famille, et, malheureusement, ma propre mère.
Il y a de nombreux problèmes que j'ai vus dans ma propre famille,
des problèmes parfois liés au manque d'argent,
parfois liés au manque d'accès aux ressources et au capital social
et qui m'ont beaucoup affecté.
Si vous aviez pu me voir quand j'avais 14 ans,
vous vous seriez demandé : « Que va-t-il arriver à ce gamin ? »
Vous auriez conclu que j'aurais eu des difficultés
à prendre ce que les universitaires appellent l'ascenseur social.
C'est un terme abstrait,
mais il touche à quelque chose qui est au cœur même
du rêve américain.
C'est quelque chose,
qui indique si des jeunes comme moi,
grandissant dans des milieux pauvres, auront une vie meilleure,
s'ils auront l'opportunité de vivre mieux qu'avant matériellement
ou s'ils vont rester dans la condition de leur milieu d'origine.
Malheureusement, l'une des choses que l'on a apprises
est que la mobilité sociale n'est pas aussi élevée qu'on le voudrait chez nous
et, curieusement, la distribution dépend beaucoup de la géographie.
Prenons l'Utah par exemple.
En Utah, un enfant pauvre s'en sort plutôt bien,
il est très probable qu'il participe au rêve américain.
Mais si vous prenez là d'où je viens,
dans le sud, les Appalaches, dans le sud de l'Ohio,
il est très peu probable que ce genre d'enfants puissent réussir.
Le rêve américain dans ces régions du pays
est littéralement juste un rêve.
Pourquoi ça se passe ainsi ?
L'une des raisons est évidemment économique ou structurelle.
Vous pensez à ces régions.
Elles sont rongées par d'exécrables tendances économiques,
bâties autour d'industries comme le charbon et l'acier,
rendant plus dur pour les gens d'avancer.
C'est certainement un problème.
Il y a aussi la fuite des cerveaux,
les gens très doués, ne trouvant pas de travail qualifié chez eux,
finissent par s'en aller ailleurs,
ils ne créent pas d'entreprise ou d’association localement,
ils finissent par aller autre part avec leur talent.
Il y a des écoles qui échouent dans ces communautés,
qui échouent à donner aux jeunes l'avantage éducatif
qui rendrait possible des opportunités.
Ces choses sont toutes importantes.
Je n'essaie pas de rabaisser ces barrières structurelles.
Mais quand je me remémore ma vie et ma communauté,
quelque chose d'autre se passait, de plus important encore.
C'est difficile à déterminer, mais c'était tout aussi réel.
Pour commencer, il y avait un réel sentiment de désespoir
dans la communauté où j'ai grandi.
Les jeunes avaient le sentiment que leurs choix ne comptaient pas.
Peu importe ce qui arriverait, peu importe les efforts,
peu importe s'ils faisaient tout pour s'en sortir,
rien de bien n'arriverait.
C'est vraiment dur de grandir avec ce sentiment.
C'est difficile de percer cet état d'esprit
et ça vous amène parfois à une grande suspicion.
Prenons un problème politique assez controversé,
l'action affirmative.
En fonction de vos tendances, vous pourriez penser que cela
est une bonne manière ou non de favoriser la diversité sur le lieu de travail
ou dans l'éducation.
Mais si vous grandissez dans ces régions,
vous voyez l'action affirmative comme un outil handicapant les gens comme vous.
C'est surtout vrai si vous venez de la classe ouvrière blanche.
Vous ne voyez pas simplement une bonne ou une mauvaise loi,
vous le voyez comme une chose qui agit secrètement,
où des gens avec du pouvoir politique ou financier
travaillent contre vous.
Et il y a de nombreuses façons de voir cette conspiration contre vous,
perçue, réelle, mais elle est là,
et elle déforme les attentes.
SI vous réfléchissez à quoi faire en grandissant dans ce monde,
vous pouvez réagir de diverses façons.
Vous pouvez vous dire : « Je ne vais pas travailler dur,
peu importe mes efforts, ça ne servira à rien. »
Une autre chose que vous pourriez dire :
« Je ne vais pas courir après les marqueurs de réussite traditionnels,
comme des études universitaires, un travail prestigieux,
je n'ai rien à voir avec les gens qui s'intéressent à ça.
Je ne serai jamais accepté. »
Quand j'ai été admis à Yale, un proche m'a demandé
si j'ai fait semblant d'être de gauche pour passer l'admission.
Sérieusement.
Et évidemment, il n'y avait pas de case à ce sujet
sur le formulaire d'inscription,
mais ça montre vraiment l’inquiétude dans ces milieux,
qu'il faille prétendre être une autre personne
pour passer à travers ces barrières sociales.
C'est un problème très sérieux.
Même en ne se laissant pas tenter par ce désespoir,
même si vous pensez par exemple,
que vos choix comptent et que vous voulez faire les bons choix,
que vous voulez le mieux pour vous et votre famille,
c'est quelque fois difficile de savoir que ces choix existent
quand on grandit dans un milieu comme le mien.
Je ne savais pas, par exemple,
qu'il fallait aller en école de droit pour devenir avocat.
J'ignorais que les grandes universités, comme les études le montrent,
sont moins chères pour les plus pauvres,
puisque ces universités reçoivent plus de donations,
et peuvent donc être plus généreuses financièrement.
Je l'ai appris en recevant ma lettre d'aide financière de Yale,
des dizaines de milliers de dollars en aide fondée sur les besoins,
terme que je n'avais jamais entendu avant.
J'ai dit à ma tante en recevant la lettre :
« Je crois que ça veut dire que pour la première fois de ma vie,
être pauvre m'a vraiment été profitable. »
Je n'avais donc pas accès à ces informations
parce que le réseau social autour de moi ne l'avait pas non plus.
J'ai appris de ma communauté comment bien tirer avec une arme.
J'ai appris à faire de très bons biscuits.
D'ailleurs, le truc, c'est le beurre congelé, pas réchauffé.
Mais je n'ai pas appris à aller de l'avant.
Je n'ai pas appris à prendre de bonnes décisions
pour les études et les opportunités
qu'il faut faire
pour s'en sortir dans cette économie du XXIe siècle liée au savoir.
Les économistes appellent la valeur que nous gagnons de nos réseaux informels,
de nos amis, collègues et famille, le « capital social ».
Mon capital social n'était pas fait pour l'Amérique du XXIe siècle,
et ça s'est vu.
Quelque chose d'autre de vraiment important se passe
et nos communautés n'aiment pas trop en parler,
mais c'est pourtant très réel.
Les enfants pauvres sont bien plus exposés
à ce que l'on appelle les expériences néfastes de l'enfance,
un joli mot pour traumatisme de l'enfance :
se faire battre ou crier dessus, être rabaissé par ses parents,
voir quelqu'un battre un parent,
voir quelqu'un se droguer ou s'alcooliser,
ce sont des exemples de traumatismes,
et ils ne sont pas rares dans ma famille.
Et surtout, ils ne sont pas fréquents dans ma famille juste maintenant,
ils s'étendent sur des générations.
Mes grand-parents,
la première fois qu'ils ont eu des enfants,
ils s'attendaient à les élever de manière convenable,
ils venaient de la classe moyenne, arrivaient à bien gagner dans l'aciérie.
Mais ce qui finit par arriver,
c'est qu'ils ont exposé leurs enfants à beaucoup de traumatismes
déjà présents depuis des générations.
Ma mère avait 12 ans quand elle a vu ma grand-mère brûler mon grand-père.
Son crime était d'être rentré ivre à la maison
après qu'elle lui a dit :
« Si tu rentres ivre, je te tuerai. »
Et elle a essayé.
Pensez à la manière comment cela peut affecter l'esprit d'un enfant.
Et on croit que ces choses-là sont vraiment rares,
mais une étude par les fonds pour l'enfance du Wisconsin a montré
que 40 % des enfants pauvres subissent des traumatismes à plusieurs reprises,
contre 29 % pour les enfants plus aisés.
Pensez à ce que cela signifie vraiment.
Si vous êtes un enfant pauvre,
presque la moitié d'entre vous feront face à plusieurs traumatismes.
Ce n'est pas un problème isolé.
C'est un enjeu très sérieux.
On sait ce qu'il advient des enfants qui ont cette vie.
Ils sont plus à même de se droguer, d'aller en prison,
d'abandonner le lycée
et, surtout,
ils auront tendance à faire à leurs enfants
ce que leurs parents leur ont fait.
Ce traumatisme, ce chaos à la maison,
est le pire cadeau de notre culture à nos enfants,
et ce cadeau passe de génération en génération.
En combinant tout ça,
le découragement, le désespoir,
le cynisme vis-à-vis du futur,
les traumatismes d'enfance,
le faible capital social
et vous commencez à comprendre pourquoi moi,
à 14 ans,
j'étais prêt à devenir une autre statistique,
un autre gamin qui n'a pas réussi à faire mentir le destin.
Mais l'inattendu est arrivé.
J'ai fait mentir le destin.
Les choses se sont améliorées pour moi.
J'ai fini le lycée.
De la fac, je suis allé en école de droit
et maintenant, j'ai un bon travail.
Que s'est-il passé ?
Eh bien, mes grands-parents,
les mêmes qui se brûlaient,
se sont vraiment repris quand je suis arrivé.
Ils m'ont donné un foyer stable,
une famille stable.
Ils se sont assurés
que lorsque mes parents ne pouvaient pas s'occuper de leurs enfants,
ils ont rempli ce rôle.
Ma grand-mère a fait deux choses qui ont vraiment compté.
Elle m'a donné un foyer paisible, me permettant de me concentrer
sur mes devoirs et les autres choses importantes.
C'était aussi une femme très attentive,
bien que n'ayant pas dépassé le collège.
Elle a bien vu le message que ma communauté avait pour moi,
que mes choix ne comptaient pas,
que les dés étaient pipés.
Une fois, elle m'a dit :
« J.D., ne deviens jamais comme ces ratés qui pensent que le jeu est truqué.
Tu peux faire tout ce que tu veux. »
Et pourtant, elle reconnaissait que la vie était injuste.
C'est dur de concilier les deux,
de dire à un gamin que la vie est injuste,
mais aussi d'inculquer en eux que les choix comptent.
Mais Mamie en était capable.
L'autre chose qui m'a vraiment aidé, c'est le corps des Marines.
On l'associe souvent avec l'armée, il en fait bien sûr partie.
Mais pour moi, le corps des Marines a été un cours de quatre ans
pour construire sa personnalité.
On m'a appris à faire mon lit, mon linge,
à me lever tôt, comment gérer mes comptes.
Des choses que ma communauté ne m'a jamais apprises.
Je me souviens de la première fois où j'ai acheté une voiture.
On m'a proposé un taux d'intérêt très très bas, de 21,9 %,
j'étais prêt à signer.
Mais je ne l'ai pas fait,
car je suis allé voir mon officier
qui m'a dit : « Ne sois pas stupide,
va à la petite banque du coin et trouve un meilleur contrat. »
Ce que j'ai fait.
Sans le corps des Marines,
je n'aurais jamais eu accès à ces connaissances.
Ça aurait été un désastre financier, sincèrement.
La dernière chose que je voudrais dire, c'est que j'ai eu de la chance
avec mes mentors et les gens
qui ont joué un rôle important dans ma vie.
Les Marines, l'État de l'Ohio, Yale
et d'autres endroits,
les gens ont vraiment été là
et se sont assurés de combler le manque de capital social
qui leur paraissait évident chez moi.
Ça vient de la chance,
mais beaucoup d'enfants n'auront pas cette chance,
et je pense que ça nous renvoie à des questions vraiment importantes
sur comment changer cela.
Il faut se demander comment donner aux enfants pauvres,
venant de foyers brisés un accès à un foyer aimant.
Il faut se demander
comment apprendre aux parents pauvres
comment mieux interagir avec leurs enfants,
avec leurs partenaires.
Il faut se demander comment donner du capital social,
des mentors aux enfants pauvres qui n'en ont pas.
Il faut réfléchir à comment on enseigne à ces enfants,
pas seulement des compétences techniques,
comme la lecture, les mathématiques,
mais aussi des compétences personnelles,
comme résoudre des conflits ou gérer ses comptes.
Maintenant, je n'ai pas toutes les réponses.
Je ne connais pas toutes les solutions à ces problèmes,
mais je sais ceci :
dans le sud de l'Ohio en ce moment,
il y a un gamin qui attend anxieusement son père,
se demandant si, quand il passera la porte,
il marchera calmement ou en titubant.
Il y a un gamin,
dont la mère s'est enfoncée une seringue dans le bras
et s'est évanouie.
Il ne comprend pas pourquoi elle ne lui prépare pas le dîner
et il va se coucher en ayant faim.
Il y a un gamin qui n'a aucun espoir dans l'avenir,
mais voudrait désespérément avoir une vie meilleure.
Ils veulent juste quelqu'un qui leur montre.
Je n'ai pas toutes les réponses,
mais à moins que la société ne commence à se poser de meilleures questions
pour savoir pourquoi j'ai eu tant de chance
et comment propager cette chance à davantage de communautés
et aux enfants de notre pays,
nous allons continuer à avoir un problème très sérieux.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)